there's a story that i you'll have to
indulge me i am so unreasonably obsessed
with this story and i'm so elated by the
turn of events in this story
according to page six kim kardashian and
skeet davidson
are breaking up
they are this whirlwind romance
went on for about nine months i think
mr davidson appeared
on some episodes of the kardashian tv
show i've never watched an episode of
the kardashian tv show but he was on it
skeet davidson who came out and was one
of the people breaking up the marriage
between kim kardashian and kanye west a
marriage where they had multiple kids
and skeet comes in and
he just is a homewrecker
and what happens now they've broken up
and i'm really happy
i'm really happy skeet davidson
actually got kim's initials in the
initials of her children with kanye west
tattooed on his neck that's going to be
very awkward it's going to be a big
payday for skeet davidson's tattoo
removal artist a few lessons here
one lesson is don't get the names of
your thrice married girlfriend's kids
tattooed on your neck that would be
lesson one but the the second lesson
here the it's the real reason that i'm
obsessed with this story
is
it's because i hate attacks on marriage
and yes kim kardashian has been married
multiple times and i don't really know
if those melodies were very valid or not
valid
but here's what i do know i know that
kim kardashian and kanye west
had multiple kids together they were
working it out
even in hollywood even with their both
of their eccentric wild personalities
and i was actually depressed when they
split up because i hate attacks on
marriage
i hate undermining marriage not just at
a personal level though i am personally
disgusted by attacks on marriage whether
that be trying to redefine marriage
whether that be trying to weaken
marriage through no fault divorce
whether that any of the attacks on
marriage but i am i am really opposed to
attacks on marriage from a political
level as well because marriage is the
fundamental political unit
so regardless of even our own personal
reactions to that or our own emotional
investment in marriage just from the
level of sheer political order and
political philosophy if you weaken
marriage your society is going to suck
okay because the libs want to convince
us that the individual the atomized
individual is the basic unit of society
and they want to break down all of the
institutions and all of the ties and all
of the families in particular that bind
us all together they want to break us
down into the individual because then
we're much easier to dominate and
control once we're all broken down into
the little individuals they can gather
us up like a bundle of sticks and do
what they want with us
that's what the libs believe
the libertarians also believe that the
individual is the basic unit of society
they don't want to gather us all
together in a bundle of sticks like the
commies do but they do hold the same
basic view of political society the
conservatives have a different view the
conservatives believe no the individual
is not the basic unit of politics
actually politics means public it's the
stuff we do together it's how we live
together in our cities and our states
and our countries and so necessarily
involves multiple people
you see echoes of this when christ
describes his church he says where two
or more of you are gathered there i am
also his description of the church as
something that is public with multiple
people held in common
or participated in in common in in the
body of christ you see that in religion
and you certainly see it in
political society regardless of what
religion
is is considered the animating spirit of
the society just in politics when we're
all together
that involves multiple people okay and
the family is the basic unit of that and
skeet freaking davidson tried to bust up
a family and i'm glad that it failed for
him i'm glad we should be we should be
very pro kanye who is trying to keep his
marriage together
kanye flawed though he may be flawed
though we all are he was trying to keep
his marriage together kim kardashian
embracing just total selfishness she did
a whole magazine spread about how in my
40s i'm just going to do me i'm just
going to do whatever i want to do that's
that's what that's what a mother of
multiple children should do right just
whatever she wants to do is that it no
that's a that's a recipe for a bad
society
and you can you can tell the rotten
fruit of this the the tree this tree of
ideology by
the fact that she dated skeet davidson
who's totally gross and now they broke
up and that's great i'm really happy
about that right now go to
expressvpn.com
knowles what if there were someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day
that would probably be pretty creepy
right
what if i told you that is exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider is allowed to store
logs of every website you have ever
visited and can legally sell these data
to anyone that is why you got to use
expressvpn i love expressvpn i trust
them on all my devices that is what i
use to secure my internet connection
through their secure servers so my isp
can't see or log what i do online many
vpns claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major vpn
provider to engineer all of their vpn
servers to run in ram and you don't have
to take my word or expressvpn's word for
it they had one of the biggest assurance
firms pwc pricewaterhousecoopers audit
their technology it's no wonder that the
verge named expressvpn the number one
vpn in the world stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online go to
expressvpn.com knowles right now find
out how you can get three months for
free
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com knowles
expressvpn.com slash and holds head on
over there right now to learn more
i'm glad you like that clip now
look we made it to 1 million subscribers
that's really great i'm getting my gold
play button from youtube it's fabulous
they haven't nuked me yet wonderful now
next goal
1 trillion i want to get to 1 trillion
subscribers i can't do that without your
help you need to ring ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you